Hardcore 3 | Les supersommations linéaires,
stables et régulières
Dans cet épisode hardcore, on va caractériser
l’ensemble des sommes infinies qui peuvent
être sommées par une supersommation linéaire,
stable et régulière. Si vous voulez la version
plus simple, je vous invite à voir l’épisode
4 sur la somme des puissances de 2, dont je
vous rappelle qu’elle est égale à -1.
Alors, il s’agit d’un épisode Hardcore,
ce qui veut dire que ça va peut-être aller
un peu vite. Pour bien comprendre ce dont
je vous vais vous parler, je vous invite à
aller voir les vidéos Wandida que j’ai
faites sur les espaces vectoriels. Ou plutôt
que je vais avoir fait, j’espère dans un
futur pas trop lointain.
Pour commencer, je vais m’autoriser de pointer
une erreur dans des vidéos de très grands
YouTubers mathématiciens, qui ont “démontré”
que la somme des entiers 1+2+3+4+5+... était
égale à -1/12. David Louapre de Science
Étonnante en avait fait un billet de blog
il y a quelques années, et Rémi Peyre, un
mathématicien dont le directeur de thèse
est un certain Cédric Villani, et dont je
vous reparlerai lorsqu’on reparlera de théorie
des systèmes de vote, a fait la remarque
dévastatrice suivante : toute supersommation
de 1+2+3+4+5+... est inconsistente. En effet,
S-2S+S = (1+2+3+4+5+...)+(0-2-4-6-8-...)+(0+0+1+2+3+...)
= 1+0+0+0+... = 1, mais il est forcément
aussi égal à 0S = 0. Du coup, si 1+2+3+4+5+...
= S, alors 1=0. Et ça, c’est pas cool.
C’est même une catastrophe mathématique
qui bousille tout, absolument tout. C’est
le cataclysme.
La preuve de Rémi Peyre est assez dévastatrice.
Elle prouve que le billet de David, la vidéo
de MicMaths, les vidéos de Numberphile et
la “preuve” originale d’Euler sont tous
faux ! Pour sauver le monde mathématique,
il faut alors s’interdire de supersommer
la somme des entiers. Plus précisément,
ceci prouve qu’un monde mathématique consistent
n’a pas de supersommation linéaire, stable
et régulier de la somme des entiers. Mais
une question se pose alors : se pourrait-il
que la supersommation des puissances de 2
conduise à un cataclysme similaire ? Quelles
sont les supersommations que l’on peut,
ou que l’on ne peut pas faire ?
Pour aller plus loin, on va devoir être un
peu plus rigoureux dans ce qu’on entend
par supersommation. Définissons l’espace
dans lequel les supersommations vivent. Ces
supersommations, en fin de compte, associent
des quantités à des suites infinies de termes
à ajouter. Il s’agit donc de fonctions
qui à des suites réelles associent des nombres,
i.e. des fonctions R^N -> R si on se restreint
aux nombres réels. Les plus malins parmi
vous pourront remplacer R par votre anneau
préféré.
Sauf qu’en fait, comme on l’a vu, on ne
va pas pouvoir supersommer toutes les séries.
En fait, la sommation classique ne permet
de sommer que les séries dites convergentes.
La sommation classique, que je vais appeler
S, est donc une fonction de l’ensemble C
des suites qui forment des séries convergentes
dans R. L’ensemble C et la sommation S ont
de bonnes propriétés : C est un espace vectoriel,
puisque la somme termes à termes de deux
suites qui forment des séries convergentes,
forme une suite dont la série sera encore
convergente. Mieux encore, leur somme sera
la même. Autrement dit, si u = (u_0, u_1,
u_2, u_3, …) et v = (v_0, v_1, v_2, v_3,
…) sont deux suites de C, alors S (\lambda
u + \mu v) = \lambda S (u) + \mu S (v). S
est donc une forme linéaire sur l’espace
vectoriel C !
On a aussi un endomorphisme linéaire e sur
C qui joue un rôle important pour les supersommations
linéaires et stables, qui est celui qui insère
un 0 en début de suite. Autrement dit, si
on définit e(u) = (0, u_0, u_1, u_2, u_3,
…), alors e est une application linéaire
de C dans C, dans le sens où e(\lambda u
+ \mu v) = \lambda e(u) + \mu e(v). Enfin,
e et S sont intimement liés, puisque e laisse
S invariant, dans le sens où S(e(u)) = S(u).
J’espère que tout va bien jusque là. Tout
ce que j’ai dit, ce sont en fait des trivialités,
mais dites dans un langage obscur. Mais ce
langage obscur va être très utile pour la
suite…
On va maintenant chercher à étendre l’espace
de supersommation à un espace vectoriel plus
grand que C. Autrement dit, on va chercher
à définir une forme linéaire T : H -> R,
où H est un sous-espace vectoriel de R^N
qui contient C. Qui plus est, on veut que
cette forme linéaire soit stable, i.e. e(H)
= H et S(e(h)) = S(h), et régulière i.e.
S(c) = T(c) pour toute suite c \in C dont
la série est convergente.
Commençons par chercher tout simplement à
ajouter la série de Minute Physics des puissances
de 2. Autrement dit, on cherche à définir
T pour H = C +u^2 R, où u^2 = (1, 2, 4, 8,
16, …). Cette somme est clairement directe
puisque u^2 n’est pas dans C. Pour que H
soit un bon candidat à être, il faut que
H soit stable par e. On sait déjà que e(C)
= C. Qu’en est-il de e(u^2 R) ? Et bien,
e(u^2) = (0, 1, 2, 4, 8, …) = ½ (1, 2,
4, 8, …) - (1/2, 0, 0, …) = u^2/2 - (1/2,0,0,0,...).
Du coup, e(u^2) \in H, ce qui prouve que e(u^2
R) \subset H. On en déduit que e(H) \subset
H.
Pour définir T sur H, il nous suffit de préciser
sa valeur sur u^2, puisque par régularité,
on connaît déjà les valeurs que T doit
avoir sur C. La condition T(e(u^2)) = T(u^2)
impose alors T(u^2) = T(½ u^2 - (1/2,0,0,0…))
= ½ T(u^2) - T(1/2,0,0,0,...) = ½ T(u^2)
- 1/2 . On a alors forcément, ½ T(u^2) = -½,
puis T(u^2) = -1. Autrement dit, si T est
une supersomme linéaire régulière et stable,
alors T(u^2) = -1. Mais à l’inverse, en
imposant T(u^2) = -1, on définit parfaitement
la fonction T. Ainsi, pour toute suite v \in
H = C+u^2 R, on sait que v = c + \alpha u^2
pour des uniques c \in C et \alpha \in R,
d’où, forcément et sans inconsistence
possible, on a alors T(v) = T(c) + \alpha
T(u^2) = S(c)-\alpha.
La construction que l’on a faite ici peut
en fait être généralisée à toute suite
géométrique dont la série est divergente,
sauf la série 1+1+1+1+.... En effet, la suite
géométrique u^x = (1, x, x^2, x^3, …) pour
x \notin ]-1,1], on a e(u^x) = (0, 1, x, x^2,
…) / x - (1/x, 0, 0, 0, …), ce qui impose
T(u^x) = T(e(u^x)) = T(u^x)/x - 1/x, d’où
(x-1)T(u^x) = -1, d’où T(u^x) =1/(1-x).
D’ailleurs la preuve que je viens de donner
est exactement la même que la sommation classique
des séries géométriques convergentes.
Ainsi, on a réussi là à étendre la supersommation
T à H = C + \oplus_ u^x
R.
Peut-on aller plus loin ? Oui ! La clé de
notre argument est en fait
la stabilité de H par e. Pour répliquer
l’argument à des espaces plus larges, il
suffit de trouver d’autres suites dont la
série est divergente, mais dont l’espace
engendré par les C + { u, e(u), e^2(u), e^3(u),
… } s’écrit C+U, où U est
de dimension finie. Ceci revient à dire que
e^n(u) \in C+Vect(u, e(u), …, e^(u)).
On a alors e^n_k(u) = c_k + \alpha_0 u_k +
\alpha_1 e(u)_k + … + \alpha_ e^(u)_k,
ce qui correspond à la récurrence u_
= c_k + \alpha_0 u_k + \alpha_1 u_ +
… + \alpha_ u_.
On peut que de telles suites sont “presque
récurrente”, ou plus exactement “définissable
par récurrence linéaire à une erreur convergente
près”. Il nous reste à déterminer la
valeur de T(u). On peut faire ceci en remarquant
que la relation ci-dessus implique que T(u)
= T(c) + \sum \alpha_k T(u), d’où T(u)
= T(c) / (1-\sum \alpha_k). On remarque là
que l’existence et l’unicité d’une
valeur que l’on peut attribuer à T(u) requiert
\sum \alpha_k \neq 1. Autrement dit, la récurrence
ne doit pas être “presque une barycentre
des n termes précédents”.
Un exemple de telle récurrence est la suite
constante (1, 1, 1, …) où, clairement,
chaque terme est une moyenne du terme précédent.
Un autre exemple plus intéressant est celui
de la suite des entiers w = (1, 2, 3, 4, …), on
a e^2(w) = (0, 0, 1, 2, 3, …) = (0, 2, 4,
6, 8, …) - (1, 2, 3, 4, …) + (1, 0, 0,
0, …) = 2 e(w) - w + (1, 0, 0, … ). Autrement
dit, la suite des entiers est bien une suite
“définissable par récurrence linéaire
d’ordre 2 à une erreur convergente près”.
Mais \sum \alpha_k = 2-1 = 1… ce qui pose
problème ! En effet, pour la suite
des entiers, chaque terme est “presque un
barycentre des 2 termes précédents”.
Mais à cela près, on peut alors définir
la supersommation T sur l’ensemble C+U,
où U est l’ensemble des suites “définissables
par récurrence linéaire qui n’est pas
un barycentre, à une erreur convergente près”.
Une dernière question que l’on peut se
poser, c’est de savoir si on a là toutes
les suites pour lesquelles on a l’existence
et l’unicité d’une supersommation. J’y
ai sans doute pas assez réfléchi mais il
me semble que oui. Mais je ne l’ai pas prouvé.
Du coup, j’invite les plus matheux d’entre
vous est de prouver la conjecture suivante
: “L’ensemble des
séries pour lesquels on peut définir une
unique supersommation linéaire, régulière
et stable est l’ensemble des
séries dont les
termes peuvent etre définis par
une
récurrence linéaire qui n’est pas un barycentre,
à une erreur convergente près.”
S’il y a des courageux parmi vous, je vous
invite à m’envoyer un pdf ou
un document avec la preuve
et je
mettrai un lien ici vers votre preuve, et
en description de cet épisode Hardcore.